certains d'entre vous s'en souviennent
peut-être c'est un peu l'ancêtre de la
presse féminine le petit écho de la mode
a permis d'habiller de nombreuses femmes
dans le passé ce magazine proposait des
patrons en papier des modèles à découper
le journal imprimé en Bretagne a fermé
depuis bientôt 30 ans mais une
association a décidé d'en raviver la
mémoire en recueillant des témoignages
des anciens reportage de France 3
reen il suffit de fermer les yeux
écouter les duul DESV le long de
l'énorme bâtisste pour s'imaginer le
bruit des lourdes machines de
l'imprimerie du petit écho de la mode et
ses fameux patrons modèles qui
habillèrent toutes les familles de
France sur cette photo des employés
datant de juillet 1947 Louisette pose à
côté de son épou de 1931 à 1972 elle a
fabriqué les pochettes des patrons comme
tous les anciens elle a été contactée
par l'association Culture et Patrimoine
de Châtel aura votre mémoire c'est notre
patrimoine alors c'est pourquoi quoi
donc on a lancé auprès des anciens de
l'imprimerie cet avis de recherche à la
fois pour retrouver tout les noms des
anciens mais surtout pour que chacun
aille dans son grenier et ce qu'on va
vous demander aussi d'aller voir quel
souvenir vous avez pu conserver du petit
écho et on va aussi
interview tous les anciens de façon à
assembler le le puzzle de ces de ces
éléments de mémoire ah ben il y avait
toute toutes les jeunes filles
rentrraient
là-dedans il avait des mariés il y en a
des plus âgés il y avait même des
personnes anciennes qui étaent là quand
on faisait le Stella tout ça c'était des
personnes âgées qui s'occupaient de la
presse là vous allez rire il fallait que
toujours je la
surveille un moment donné il pe avoir de
la colle ça faisait un vage et la
machine P il fallait que je suis
toujours là je ne pouvais pas bouger
j'avais toujours au d'aller au TER et
encore Jean-Claude a été mackettiste
photograpur pendant 10 ans à
l'imprimerie et il vient confier un
objet au futur musée du Petit écho de la
mode alors cette plaque c'est un cliché
typo en cuivre c'estd que la typographie
donc c'est le principe de l'impression
en relief donc ce cliché en cuivre
servait surtout à des forts tirages
cette opération de collecte et de
souvenirs de témoignage s'inscrit dans
un vaste projet de réhabilitation de
l'imprimerie musée salle de conféren
centres socio-culturel mais aussi salle
de spectacle avec ce petit supplément
d'âme des endroits qui ne veulent pas
disparaître en
silence et c'est la fin de